over the last couple of years
everybody's gotten really excited about
drones right flying machines that we can
control flying machines that are under
our agency and volition I can see that
people have come out of the woodwork
hobbyists are emerging in-store
everybody's obsessed with drones and of
course the technology has improved
exponentially over the last couple of
years and I think today for the first
time I had a revelation I finally
understood the power of the drone and it
took me back to my childhood now you
guys remember the first time you got a
remote-controlled car there came a
moment where you assumed that this
remote-controlled car was now a part of
your mental scaffolding this was the
feeling that you felt with a
remote-controlled car now of course you
grow up and you get over silly things
like the Hat because fundamentally it's
a toy but I think what the drone has
done is it has brought back that
excitement of controlling an external
vehicle and bringing it under conscious
control and there's precedent for this
idea from what's going on in the mind
during these moments it goes back to the
work of the cognitive philosophers David
Chalmers and Andy Clark
they wrote Natural Born cyborgs they
wrote the extended mind thesis they were
talking about how the devices such as
smartphones have become part of our
cognitive scaffolding they're beyond the
skin back but they're still tethered to
the contents of our mind our mind a
feedback loop of brains tools and
environment so realizing that minds like
ours are made for mating with
non-biological props and scaffoldings
you can see them the invigoration the
freedom the liberation that the drones
bring to our cognitive apparatus because
the drone frees us from gravity it frees
us from the limitations of our weighing
bodies on the floor it frees us into the
feeling of flight and so for the mind
especially when you have the
drones that can be connected to the
screen where you can see the drones POV
I mean I think that you literally mind
mesh with it and eventually the drone
starts to feel like a part of your mind
decoupled from your body radically
extending the boundaries of selfhood and
of course this is a really fun
experience it's freeing it's liberating
it feels like you can fly you know it's
it's akin to the childlike historical
desire to to move beyond our limitations
to soar above the heavens and you know
it's really exciting to witness the
Mason sea of such an industry that is a
literalization of a human dream that has
persisted through millennia
so that's drones
[Music]